INDIVIDUALS CHOOSE TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPPOSING VIEWS WITH SUCH
DISTURBING BEHAVIOR."
ON CAPITOL HILL, SENATE
REPUBLICANS DELIVERING ON THEIR
PROMISE FOR OPEN DEBATE ON
IMMIGRATION.
IT WAS PART OF THE DEAL THAT
ENDED THE FIRST GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN THIS YEAR.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL LOOKS
AT WHERE THINGS ARE HEADED ON
THE HILL.
>> WE WANT TREMENDOUS BORDER
SECURITY BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
DEMOCRATS SUPPORT FOR DACA AND
THEY ARE STARTING THAT PROCESS
TODAY.
WE THINK THERE IS A GOOD CHANCE
GETTING DACA DONE IF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SERIOUS AND THEY
WANT TO DO IT.
>> HOPEFUL TONE AS THE SENATE
LAUNCHES DEBATE ON THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION.
REPUBLICAN SENATORS GRASSLEY,
CORN AND BRUNO, TILLIS,
LANGFORD, COTTON, ERNST, ROLLING
OUT AN IMMIGRATION PLAN.
IT WOULD ADDRESS THE YOUNG
PEOPLE BROUGHT TO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY BY THE PARENTS, FUN
BORDER SECURITY WITH A WALL
WHILE ENDING SO-CALLED CHAIN
MIGRATION AT THE VISA LOTTERY.
TOP SENATE LEADERS NOTED THE
CHALLENGE AHEAD BUT INSISTED
THEY CAN REACH A DEAL.
>> AT EVERY CRITICAL MOMENT IN
THIS COUNTRY, WE HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO DO WHAT NEEDED TO BE
DONE.
TO MOVE THE BALL DOWN THE FIELD.
>> IT WON’T BE EASY BUT WE ARE
ALL GOING TO TRY BECAUSE OF THE
GRAVITY OF THE ISSUES.
AND BECAUSE WE KNOW THIS WEEK
WILL BE A TEST OF WHETHER THE
SENATE CAN STEER THE SHIP OF
STATE THROUGH THE STORM HE ASKED
OF WATERS.
I BELIEVE IT CAN.
>> THE HOUSE IS ANOTHER STORY.
THREE -- EMPHASIZING BORDER
PROTECTION.
>> FIND AN ACCOMMODATION FOR
THEM BUT NO AMNESTY.
WE CANNOT HAVE INDIVIDUALS GET
IN THE QUEUE IN FRONT OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
LEGALLY WORKING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS FOR YEARS.
>> HOW ARE PUBLIC AND COVERS AND
JIM JORDAN SAYS IT REFLECT WHAT
AMERICAN VOTERS WANT.
>> WHAT THEY WANT IS BORDER
SECURITY.
BUILD THE BORDER SECURITY WALL.
END CHAIN MIGRATION.
GET RID OF THE CRAZY VISA
LOTTERY.
TWO THINGS IN A WAY THAT MAKE
GOOD COMMON SENSE.
DO THOSE THINGS FIRST.
>> CALIFORNIA HOUSE DEMOCRAT
SAYS HER SIDE BLEW IT.
>> IT WAS A REAL MISTAKE THAT WE
DIDN’T USE LEVERAGE WE HAD.
WE HAD A COUPLE OPPORTUNITIES
COMING UP.